Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. It
like, to be honest, I'm a cybernetic
organism, living tissue yoga.
It is very late at night.
I am packing for an island to get away.
Why does that matter?
Because it reminds me of one of the
sponsors for today's podcast Mizzen and
main. Why? Because the only
dress shirt that I'm taking,
I normally hate dress shirts
is from mizzen and main,
specifically the Beckett Blue Gingham.
The reason or the reasons I should say
is because I can throw it in my bag in a
duffle,
not worry about ironing,
not worry about any kind of wrinkling
and then throw it on where it maybe four
or five nights out of seven
without washing it. It won't smell.
It's antimicrobial. It is
made of stretch, fabric,
sweat wicking,
athletic.
I could wear it for a hike in
between dinners if I want to do it,
probably wouldn't do that,
but mizzen and main has really delivered
on the all around all purpose dress
shirt.
They're fancy enough.
You can fool people into thinking
that you had them custom tailored,
but they're also rough
enough and resilient enough
that you can toss them into
the bottom of a duffle bag or backpack,
pull it off and put it on in
a bathroom at a restaurant.
Let's say. Uh, hundreds of pro
athletes love this brand. Uh,
people who don't fit well into dress
shirts, otherwise like NFL allpro JJ watt.
And the last time these guys
were featured on the show,
Mizzen and main sold out of
every item that they featured.
So if you're interested in checking
them out, I'd recommend taking a look.
Just go to tim.blog/shirts and you can
see that one shirt that I'm packing that
I always pack the Becket Blue Gingham
in addition to a couple of my other
favorites.
And you can enter Tim,
that's Capitol Tim at
checkout for free shipping.
If you use this code
before September 15th,
that's 2017 to buy a dress
shirt mizzen and main,
we'll donate a brand new dress shirt to
the relief efforts in southern Texas.
That's in addition to the thousand shirts
that are already being donated through
Jj Watson.
Credible efforts to put,
or I should say rather help Houston and
the surrounding communities get back on
their feet. So there you have
it. Check it out. Take a look.
Even if it's just to take a peek at
this one shirt, the Becket Tim dot.
Blog forward slash shirts. Again, that's
Tim dot. Blog forward slash shirts.
This episode is brought
to you by kettle and fire,
which makes some of the best bone broth
and certainly the most convenient that
I've ever found and I have a big stack
of them on my kitchen counter right now.
I have one container every morning and
this first came recommended to me by past
podcast guests such as Amelia Boone,
who is a four time world champion in
world's toughest mudder, Spartan race,
etc. And Dr Dominic D'agostino, the
incredible hulk of scientific research.
You check him out too.
But there are a few things that make
kettle and fire special. Number one,
they are the first shelf stable.
In other words,
never frozen bone broth that
uses bones from 100% grass fed,
organically raised animals,
so you are what you eat,
ate,
if that makes sense.
So it's very important that you understand
if you're consuming animal protein,
what they consumed. They also use
longer cook times, 20 plus hours,
which means more collagen and
other nutrients. For instance,
they contain 19 times more Collagen,
then one of their close competitors
and an independent lab confirm this.
I'll leave the competitor's name out
of it because I don't want to get sued,
but that's the case and it is not frozen.
So thanks to many millions of
dollars of packaging equipment.
Their bone broth doesn't require
freezing or shipping with dry ice.
So like I said,
it's just sitting on my kitchen counter
in these boxes and then I can heat them
up.
They're basically ready to drink,
heat them up on the stove top or in a
microwave and you are ready to rock and
roll. And you'll also get a nice
payload of Glucosamine, glycine, uh,
along with the Dalton and everything
else that I mentioned. So check it out.
I've been hugely pleased
with this and like I said,
had been consuming it every morning.
It gives you about,
I want to say 20 grams of protein,
which is a nice little slow carb diet
boost if that's what you're looking for.
Then I'll typically sip this Advate,
very large camping coffee Mug as
I do some writing or journaling,
so you'll have it. Check
it out. It's delicious.
I favor the chicken,
but uh,
each to his own or her own.
So check it out.
Kettle and fire.com forward slash Tim and
you can receive 20% off of your entire
order. Take a look, Kevin,
fire.com forward slash Tim
boom ticket. Just say,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show. I have music on the mind.
It's a Friday as I record this pet,
way too much tea,
and that gives me a little bit of
personality. So let's jump into it.
This episode of the podcast features
Stuart Copeland on Twitter at Copeland
music who is considered one of
the top 10 drummers of all times.
Certainly one of the greatest
drummers in rock and roll history.
He was one of the founding
members of the police,
has been inducted into the rock and
roll hall of fame and is a grammy award
winning musician. Stuart is
amazing. I've spent time with him.
He reminds me a bit of
doc in back to the future.
It show kids Mati it chuck
kids. But uh, I digress.
He is a fantastic storyteller and a very,
very well spoken smart guy in this
conversation, which is very wide ranging.
We delve into early lessons in surviving
and how to survive the music industry,
why entrepreneurs never get a day off.
And certainly any self directed musicians
or creatives are entrepreneurs in the
sense of him, but in dead to
make something from nothing.
How the police developed a unique sound
and the decision that changed everything
for them and much more.
This interview comes from my
television show. Fearless fear, less,
less in quotation marks.
Since your goal is not to be fearless,
but to learn to fear less.
And in this show I interviewed world class
performers on stage about how they've
overcome doubt, conquered fear,
and made their toughest decisions.
We recorded about three hours of material,
only one was used for the TV show.
So this podcast is almost entirely
new content that did not appear on TV,
but I highly recommend a few things.
Number one,
you can watch the entire first episode
of fearless with illusionist and
endurance artists, David Blaine,
and he does a bunch on stage.
You can wash it all for
free@att.net forward slash fearless,
all spelled out, no parentheses.
So att.net forward slash fearless.
So definitely check that out. And to
see all episodes of this new TV show,
you can use directv or you can use the
APP at direct TV that Com and that's
direct TV now.
So you can check that out.
D I r e c t v.com and that is it for now.
So let's move on.
Please enjoy this conversation with
the one and only Stewart Copeland.
You want to fearless? I'm
your host, Tim Ferris.
And on this stage will be deconstructing
world class performers of all different
types to uncover the specific
tactics they've used, overcome doubt,
tackle some of their hardest decisions,
and ultimately succeed on their own terms.
So imagine yourself a founding member
of one of the most successful rock bands
of all time.
What happens when you break up from any,
that might be the end of the story,
but from my guest tonight,
it was just getting started
with no prior experience.
He went on to score films for Francis
Ford Coppola and Oliver Stone composed for
ballet and opera and even take pilgrimages
to Africa where he played drums with
hungry lions. I am not kidding. He's
a founding member of the police,
a member of the rock
and Roll Hall of fame.
And for the last three decades he's been
one of rolling stone's top 10 drummers
of all time.
Please welcome musician master
and Madman Stewart Copeland
[inaudible].
So just,
uh,
we're going to get to the
backstory because I was
kidding with some of the guys
when we were doing all the research that
if I wrote a screenplay that covered
the arc of your life,
I think it would get rejected or
heavily edit as being too unrealistic.
We're going to get to that. It's just
a fascinating story, but what was
your mother's background?
Well, she's British.
Her job was analyzing French and European
train schedules and so it was very,
if she was a spy,
but it was in an office,
it was a bureaucratic version of analyzing
says for sorting out bombing runs,
getting supplies.
And it was called the Soe and the ladies
of the Soa as almost all women by the
way, unsung heroes and people are
now writing books about the Soa,
these women who fought this kind of
bureaucratic data war and now data,
we all understand data. But back then
it was kind of number NCU met my father.
They got married during the war and um,
that's my parents.
She's a bitch. She,
when we went to Lebanon,
she was an archeologist and she
wrote books. In fact, my mother,
a very bookish and her books are the
kind of books that you don't read in a
bookstore. The kind of books that the
people who write books that you read,
use those research. The first
word in her book, you know,
one of our books is the second
word is 14 syllables. Log
started off easy. Yeah,
yeah. It's fine. Not Great.
But then it gets more and more
impenetrable as you go into it.
What was it like growing up as the
American in Cairo or in Beirut?
While there were other Americans
to mostly oil families.
All of the kids at the American community
school of Beirut, a rumored to, uh,
the American community schools,
all the Aramco kids,
all the families in Saudi Arabia,
the American families around,
they sent their kids to
this school in Beirut.
And in my generation was
the first generation where
the Saudi Arabians and the
Gulf Arabs with their new wealth
began to send their kids for a western
education.
And so I in my age group started to see
Saudi princes in my class and got to
know them.
A one such was Osama
bin Ladin in your class?
Not In my class. He would
have been a quite a big in
your school and that school.
Quite a few. If I had known him,
I would have kicked his ass.
Yeah.
Well, I mean I have to ask, did
you, so you met and interacted
with them? No, no, no.
He was years after. Right after I got
it and I got it. What, by the way? Yes.
I went back to Beirut years later.
Um,
and it's all Arabic mouth and
they're all there. The Lebanese,
the most murky there.
One of the richest countries,
most developed countries in the Middle
East and they rule in the Arab world.
Anybody who's running any
of these probably Lebanese
and they have no resources.
They have huge civil strife,
huge ethnic tension.
But they've been through their civil war
and they've got it resolved in just the
Lebanese.
They are all about education.
So the American community school educating
these kids to go and conquer America,
which they do. You know, there's
a Lebanese ghetto here in, uh,
Los Angeles is called Beverly Hills.
What did, what did you want
to be when you were a kid?
I,
I can't remember any time before I
wasn't a musician and I don't remember,
you know, was seven or something
like that. I just never, ever,
when I was actually in college, I thought,
I don't actually want to play music.
I want to organize it. So I, you know,
I studied journalism and other
aspects of the entertainment industry,
but the drums just kept
the siren song me back.
When did you leave the Middle
East? I left the Middle East, uh,
and the mid sixties,
I would have been 14 or 15,
something like that.
And I was already playing in my high
school band and Beirut by that time.
And I got to boarding school in England
and a couple of things nobody had ever
heard of where I come from. Where do
you come from? Well, Lebanon. Well,
where's that, you know, uh, the other
thing was that I didn't realize it,
but a lot of my vocabulary wasn't
English. Uh, they speak in Beirut,
they speak Arab, a friend
glaze, which is the Arabic,
but the sophisticated bay,
Rudy's speak French, but English,
English American was invading
the university was American.
The hospital built by
American missionaries, the
Americans in the Middle East,
by the way, during my time
where most part from my father,
the Americans built hospitals
and universities and
American money was going into
the Middle East from Christian
organizations, um, for missionaries.
And so Americans were known for
no strings attached. Good stuff,
you know,
because it was the French and the British
and the old emperor imperial powers
that had the bad rap.
We soon earned a bad rap.
But in those days the
Americans were much loved.
What brought you to even, why'd you guys
move? Well, I was evacuated because,
uh, after the Philby
thing, it got hot. And uh,
so my father just suddenly had to
get the family out of dodge. Um,
Lebanon at that time was
always, you know, 1958.
There was a civil war there at
that time while I was there.
And it was bombs in the night.
We had to fill the bathtub with water
and stock up with food and, and so on.
And there was sand bags in
the streets. And uh, uh,
and I actually in those days it
was put out by the United States,
Sixth Fleet show up, which is another
reason I was real proud to be American.
They showed up in 1958,
I think Eisenhower was president
and that was it. Civil war over,
uh, they, they just,
just for show they landed a whole
platoon or whatever on the beach with the
tanks and everything and did a
display of these enormous 10,
okay, well let's all go back to
work now, shall we? You know,
and there was no violence to I,
it was just a display.
It was like a 4th of July
exhibition kind of thing.
These are the kind of toys
we got to play with folks.
Anybody who has any questions and,
uh,
because our, as I said
before, because our,
our status there was very positive.
We were loved there that we, you know,
and they, they're, there was an
election coming up and they're very,
I won't bore you with the complicated
politics, but there was a,
an election coming up and
there's a lot of vegetation.
And so the American showed up.
They have a peaceful election.
They elected the, not the, not American
guy, actually, the, you know, they,
my father was glad,
but they elected Shahab instead of
the guy that the Americans wanted.
But it was fine. He did a fine job and
civil war over, but it was always there.
There had three major religions there
who had to share power and the Christian
has ruled the country.
Uh,
then there's the Sunni and the Shia who
were at each other's throats as much.
They all, you know, is
a triangle. And, um,
that triangle with the influx of
Palestinians just couldn't hold.
And so civil war and then there were
the really awful civil wars, you know,
the same as what's going on in Syria now.
They eventually blew over and in Beirut,
Lebanon has probably more
able to withstand the Syrian
war next door because in
Lebanon, no, no, no, no, no. We've been,
there were not that Sunni's are fine.
The shear fine law lets every,
you know,
everybody gets to go back to work instead
of the u s six leaks showing up the
civil war,
the civil war in Syria next door.
And their own history means they're not
about to pick a fight anytime soon. Yeah.
But before I was born in Syria where
the family was living before I was born
there, my mother was pregnant
with my brother, Ian, uh,
comes up in conversation a lot.
Um,
and they had a problem with their
general, who is they, you know,
their dictator who was
running the place of Fauzi,
Al Shabaab or whatever his name was.
And he was, you know, starting to get,
starting to talk to the
root skis and so on.
And so you got to get rid of this guy.
And so they figured out,
this is my father's idea that I tell you
what, why don't we have a rent a mob?
Go and attack an American diplomats
house or rent them up hours.
Uh, and so, uh, and
then then the, uh, our,
our new kernel that we'd been shining up,
he can get the soldiers out to go and
put down this riot and Wallace soldiers
around and they can take over
the radio station and the palace.
And that's how they did it in those days.
And he be colonel who
took over the palace,
thought he was working
against American interests,
but in fact the other colonel Heather
to undisclosed with the actual guy.
And so his system was getting other
people to do the dirty work. But okay.
So this attack happens on the family home,
the Copeland family home in Damascus,
Syria and a,
they're late at my father's on the phone
to bay route and they show up. Oh, great,
great. Go Bang. Oh No, they got god.
That's not, you know, and Bang Bang.
And the famous line that he had,
which is as our family thing is, uh,
he says, ah, I'm going to have to hang
up now they're shooting at me personally.
No,
I never even believed these stories. Uh,
because it was my bad pellet. I mean,
he used to say,
never let the facts ruin a good story,
but the history books are being
written now about that period.
And my father's in there, oh my
God. And according to the books,
and I didn't realize this until I
found in the family archives, uh, some,
uh, uh, newspaper clippings about
it. He chased them off with a gun.
He had a gun.
My father had a handgun.
I never saw him with a gun or a he,
you know,
Alabama kid chases up bandits
with a handgun. And, uh,
there were in one of the Persian
rugs there, bullet holes.
And my sister's got that rug,
uh, because during those days,
the diplomatic wives and all the wives
would go to Iran or Persia as it was
known.
And by all this incredible stuff.
So I have in my studio these Persian
rugs that are older than I am.
They've been in the family
longer than I am. And in fact,
another little digression, the patterns
on those Persian rugs, but these strange,
the geometric and yet curved
lines and everything like that.
And now I was crawling around face first
on those rugs from the age of zero all
the way up.
And I just looked at those rugs the other
day and I realized that pattern is my
music,
that my music is exactly that.
The way it's a combination of symmetry
and wild abandon the way the different
colors interact with the other.
I realize it was like printed when I
was nose first phase first and these
Persian rugs.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to dial this back
a little bit to college.
How did you choose where to go to college?
How did you end up going where he did?
Ah, well, I was a draftable American.
Uh,
in spite of my pride in my country,
we were fighting a war in Vietnam
at the time for which my brother had
volunteered. My brother Ian,
the heroic brother, actually,
not only did he have a motorcycle in
high school, but he went to Vietnam.
He volunteered, he came
back, a decorated hero. Um,
[inaudible]
I, you know, I can't, you know, battalion
citation, presidential citation,
purple heart, bronze star of
he found himself, you know,
and he came back and became an agent.
Never saw a gun for the rest of his life,
but he started,
he was a wild kid who discovered that.
And he came back and when he came back,
he was spat on and reviled.
And it was a tragedy of the Vietnam War.
How the American people saw it because
we were afraid that we could be sent out.
Well, the voluntary, those
weren't volunteers over
there. That could be me. Uh,
and he did volunteered and
he was fine until the war,
the first Gulf War. And when he heard the
crackle of the radios, the thump, thump,
thump, thump of the helicopters,
it came back and it, it almost,
he had a psychosis for it.
And then when the soldiers came home
as conquering heroes, he, you know,
that was the, that's what, how
he should have been treated.
Every single one of the soldiers in
his platoon ended up as heroin addicts.
They didn't make it,
none of them made it.
He died of Agent Orange a few years ago,
taken by melanoma. That's how the
Vietnam War generation was treated.
Um, and I didn't want any
part of that personally.
And by the time I came along, I'm,
I'm at the end of the baby boom. Um,
and by the time I got to college,
there were planting,
they built all these colleges and
capacity for the baby boom. Well,
at the time I came along and
would kind of wait it out of it.
So it was easy for me to get into college.
You know, there's all this space. Uh,
but how the hell did we get there?
How did you end up going to college? How
am I going to go and cut? Okay. So, uh,
we had a lottery system.
Everybody, senator's kids,
everybody was getting drafted
and so they had a lottery system.
Whatever your birth date, you'd
take your date out of, uh,
they pull the dates out of
a hat. Okay. September 27,
that's one. Okay. January 18,
that's two. Okay. April
nine, that's three.
And you go down to all
the 365 days of the year.
And you get a number of mine was July 16
and depending on what state you are in,
um, they had a quota. Alabama had a quota
of [inaudible]. And if you're in a, an a,
an Alabama and you registered to vote
in Alabama and you're a number was a 47
year drafted. If your number
was high, 200 or above,
you're probably safe.
Well,
the draft board for people who turned
18 outside of America was zero.
They had a quota of zero.
So as long as they didn't come to America,
I was legally not drafted. I
registered and I, and everything.
But then I got my number 287,
uh,
and then it will say,
so then I continued my university
education in America, Berkeley,
Berkeley, Berkeley. Why did
you choose Berkeley? Um,
because I'd outgrown the small school
that I was at and I want it to go to a big
school with 40,000 students
and learn from, uh, you know,
Nobel winners and so on.
Just felt like a bigger battery place.
It's a great school and they're in
my backyard. Uh, tell, tell me about,
and tell us about the, uh, the
college event. Set the tip sheet.
They've now you're getting,
okay,
now you have found a question for which
I ain't going to have to make up material
and it's true. I've been trying, don't,
I don't mean by, by, by making it up.
I mean like that's a question I've never
answered before. Alright, Mazel Tov.
Thank you. Ah, college event
was an idea of my older brother,
miles who was the, the, uh, the
businessman of the family. And,
um, basically I called up all the
colleges around the west and I said,
tell me about what concerts do you put on?
How much did you spend Frank Zappa,
how much did he cost Janice Joplin? How
much did he pay? How'd they go down?
How did the thick of it?
And they just send me back their report
of the Gig and I printed it onto what
was called a tip sheet. Um, it
just information, just data.
And I would send it to all the colleges
and the West so they can see the,
you know, Uc Santa Barbara can
see that UCLA paid Frank Zappa,
you know, $10,000. They trashed
the dressing rooms or whatever.
And so the colleges could
use this as a data sheet.
And I sold advertising to the record
companies and so on and so forth.
And I was a little business venture.
And then that drumming,
it was just while I was into
my second or third edition,
and then I'd call it calling up,
selling the stuff and getting the
letters and the college people sent.
All I had to do is print their letters
about what agent rip them off and didn't
treat them on that agent.
The guy who deals with universities,
they have a lot of money. These colleges.
Oh my God. And so suddenly I had power,
power, but it was all going
great until that drumming thing.
And there was a band over in London,
needed a drummer and it was summers.
I went over to the London plan,
a band and it never came back.
What was the,
uh,
what were the most important lessons
that you took from putting together that
tip sheet?
Uh,
that you have to do it
yourself was the main thing.
And you have to think of everything.
And there's the entrepreneur,
unlike a job holder doesn't get
a day off. And My, you know,
a roommate, you know, people
in the, in the building,
they had jobs and they knew when they
go to work and they knew when they come
home and they got their check, but
they have to go to work. I didn't,
as an entrepreneur, you don't have
to go to work. You're always working.
You can never not be at work.
And so you know, of my sins,
I have seven children and my
sons, you know, for instance,
just take two for instance, one as an
entrepreneur, filmmaker has a band,
he's just,
he's always picking up the phone,
he's hustle bustle and the
other has a nine to five job.
They are both happy as clams. The nine to
fiver, he can't imagine what it's like.
And six o'clock he gets into his car,
he is free.
His life just as it belongs to him.
He can watch TV,
you can have friends and go out to dinner.
He just lives a great life.
Next morning he gets up, goes to work.
Work's like hell, enjoys his job.
And then Jordan, he, he would not be
able to thrive under those conditions.
And what do you mean? I have
to get up? You know, uh,
it's more of a question. No, no,
no, you can't go to bed. Right.
I remember being told once,
I said,
if you work diligently eight
hours a day for perhaps 10 years,
then you can get promoted to boss
and work 12 hours. Yes, exactly.
When the punk bands in London in 1977
desired to play reggae because it was,
you know, for, for a punk bands, the
only form of chill was dub reggae,
which is still hostile.
Still pissed off,
but chill.
And so there was no such thing as chill
punk music. You just can't slow it down.
And you know, and so the, the,
the, the, the punk rockers
would chill to dub reggae,
which meant that I could fall right into
that top or heat. And to his credit,
he figured out, let's see, the
backbeat doesn't go on two and four,
so he's sitting there and his drums
and he's signaling and then that,
and he had to learn how to
do it and he could do it.
I already can do it.
And so we develop that sound and the
police, which is kind of important.
And we didn't actually play reggae
strictly the way it comes out of Jamaica.
We did our own thing to it,
but it was elemental.
It wasn't learning it
the way topper had do.
It just was that secret weapon that
I got from my friends in Lebanon.
So I call Stinko and I say Sony, he
wants to join the band. He's like fancy.
He's in, that's said no brainer
water. You went, why, why, what?
What are we waiting for? And I
think, Dude, calm down, calm down.
We can't afford him. He's a, you know,
I had to explain to Andy, there's no
record company. I'm the record company,
you know, illegal records. You know,
I printed them myself staying and I put
the records into the bags ourselves and
I would let lecherous I did the artwork
myself and I called up the stores.
My son, we got, I'm the
record company management.
I'm the manager to an agent.
I'm booking the gigs to roadie.
That's you.
And uh, so we, you know,
I, I'm really flattered,
but you're going to leave after two weeks,
you know, we can't, you know, you're,
you know, you've got a life,
you've got the expenses, you
know. Um, and he insisted.
He said, no, no, no. I'm canning all
my sessions. I want to be in the band.
He had played with soft machine or
burden, uh, the animals. You know,
he had a list of credits
as long as your arm,
but you didn't want to be a side man
anywhere to be in the band and to be for
the band,
to be his band.
And of course I'm going to get rid of
that other guitars, you know that, right?
And I say, sure, sure sir. I
didn't think about that. Um,
and we actually did play a couple
of shows with two guitars, but, um,
so he insisted and so, and, and
by this time thing going up, no,
he's an actual musician. He's in the
back not going to calm down. And finally,
you know, it's either, either
he's in or I'm out. Oh, okay.
So,
and he's in the band.
And immediately Andy has
deep musical training.
I didn't have to show them an
e chord or a d or an a chord.
He knows he flattens seventh
carry the, you know, you know,
he really, and as soon as him and
sting put their heads together,
out of nowhere, sting writes a song
as a result of Andi joining the group.
There was another surprise in
store for us all, which was the,
in our punk band, the singing
was, ah, Dah and thinking do that.
And that's all I ever heard him do because
that's what we did. And that kind of,
that genre was all shouting. Yeah. Um,
but we had one last Andy Summers Gig to
do. He said, look, I've got one last Gig,
this guy in Germany and I'm going to
go over and by way he needs a drummer.
So you got a Gig to so dandy and I went
over to Germany with Everhard Sherner
this high concept thing where he's
got jazz saxophone, he's gotten lazy.
Sorry I'm, he's got a ballet
dancer and they punk group. Yeah.
And for a punk group or you
know, actually, you know,
we've got a buddy who plays bass,
why don't we bring him over to sheriffs?
They brought suit.
So the three of us are there as the punk
group as a part of this multi, you know,
mix and match kind of
show and the jazz singer,
the obligatory American jazz singer,
jazz singer chick.
And she had the shoulder down.
She's out of tune and liked it that way.
The jazz attitude.
And she's a punk van. And one day, so,
but long story short, we, the first show,
we were not unprepared. We, you know,
the, the a all kinds of
bedlam and craziness. And we
got the first shower door.
We don't even know how we're going to
finish the set that at one point she
slinks off,
but she does her
mother slinks off like that.
And there's the Mike stand.
Then there we are and we're not
quite sure what, what to do next
based buyer walks up to the microphone
and the sound out of his mouth.
A keening wailing sound that
was soaring high with the stars,
with a pain and a yearning and not growing
feeling of the cosmos coming down to
take us away and the heart of
this wave and the Andy and I.
Fuck me.
And so the police was
born, well, two things.
I didn't know he could write songs and I
didn't know he could sing like that and
that it was sort of Andy
who made it all the,
the whole thing come together. The
cocktail come together with the police.
How did you decide on certain visual
aspects of the band or other stylistic
decisions like the bleach
blonde hair for instance? Well,
we would never be caught dead
discussing such matters. Uh,
the bleach blonde hair came from,
uh,
the fact that sting's wife was an actress.
She had an agent,
she took one look at her
client's husband and said,
that guy belongs in front of a camera.
And she would send him for a modeling
jobs and in advertising and so on.
And he would get every gig.
Um,
and one day they wanted a punk band
for a Wrigley's chewing gum commercial.
And so, uh, they called, you
know, he got the Gig and said,
well, I have a punk band.
I am myself a punk.
Um,
so they got Andy and I out there as well,
but they didn't think we looked snarly
enough. I know. Let's peroxide their hair.
And uh, so the, the, the, the
wardrobe people just like the ladies,
he got back there, they made us look the
part and we looked at each other, say,
that's kind of cool.
And so we got our blonde look from
a Wrigley's chewing gum commercial
somewhere they ad didn't run,
I guess it didn't test well or something.
And,
uh,
somewhere in a vault
somewhere is that ad of a,
the three blood heads blonde for the
first time. I actually am blonde.
Okay. This is real. It
actually I'll get gray,
but I'm blonde too.
But alas,
the locust sick,
my hair a common cause
of male pattern baldness,
you know, Stinko and I, music fulfills
a different purpose in our lives.
Uh, for me it's celebration, it's a party.
And for sting perhaps it's more
of a, um, an escape, you know,
a peaceful, beautiful place that
he can go to. And those two things,
when we were codependent,
we,
the differences between
us really filled gaps.
And so it was very synergistic.
Um, but as we, you know,
the first two albums were recorded
with that, the first album,
it was just us in the studio and we got
in there and we recorded an album in 20
minutes.
And then the second album was after we'd
started to get somewhere in America and
we've been playing and we're getting
great reviews and burning down the house
night after night and we're feeling
really great and they say you have your
whole life to write your first album and
six months to write your second draft.
And so there were back in
the studio and you know,
we've got half an album worth of
material but we got to get a new album.
And so that's second album. We just came
up with it. We were full of ourselves.
We're, you know, we were
validated by, you know, we,
we know that we're the coolest. So we
had the confidence in our second album,
just was all creativity.
Had a bunch of hits on that record too.
So the third album,
we're going into the studio and
now we are not just us anymore.
This was the beginning of the police
becoming something that isn't our,
just our little thing anymore. It's bigger
than us. And there's a momentum there.
There's a record company that is counting
on hits and we were there in Holland.
In fact,
recording the third albums and yacht.
I'm on data and the record
company are actually in the
studio. Is that a hint? No,
I think the other one's hit and it was
like commerce was in the room with us and
it really bummed us out kind of like that.
But we were still had had a buzz
going and it was us against the world.
The next two albums which we recorded
in monster at and the Caribbean far,
far away, 12 hours from the
nearest record company executive.
And there was just the
three of us and by now, um,
we were not so codependent.
But when it comes to music,
I kind of like working with an orchestra.
And by the way,
I write music for 60 piece orchestra.
They don't talk back.
I put every note and how they play it
on the thing that Piccolo players been
playing Piccolo his whole career.
But he's going to play exactly what I put
on the page. And it's not Deta Dah Dah.
It's data data with a little diminuendo
at the end with articulate the Staccato,
the third note, and then the, the,
the, you know, the slur over in,
I put on the page in ink in Italian,
exactly in 60 guys.
And that's how it works. And guess
what? Steam likes to do that too. Uh,
and he's real good at it and he has kind
of a track record of being successful
at it.
Um,
but what he wants to do is kind of
different from what I want to do.
The purpose of music for him has
a different purpose for me. And,
and we came together for the reunion tour
and it was so hard for us to make the
pieces fit back together. Cause
guess what, 20 years ago by,
and we'd grown and I had lost,
I'd gotten out of the habit of the
bass player turnaround and telling me
anything, you know, uh,
and he'd gotten out of the habit of this
world war three going behind his left
shoulder and he comes over
to, uh, well, maybe not,
you know. Oh, okay. Maybe not.
And, uh, you know, with the
best of intentions, you know,
I'm sure sting looks at the
mirror every morning, says, okay,
today I'm going to let Stewart be Stewart
and I would look in the mirror in
the morning. Anything he wants,
I will be there for him.
Any scintilla of, of a new,
I will listen and I will do my best to
remember what he told me. And you know,
and that gets us through
the first hour of rehearsal.
This is the thing about Francis Coppola
as he can spot talent and his, you know,
very different from somebody like Oliver
Stone for whom I've scored as well,
who stone himself owns every frame,
every aspect of the film comes from his
creativity. And that's what he does,
you know, uh, he doesn't
want people to clever ideas.
He wants people who are clever, it
carrying out his ideas. Unfortunately,
he's got really great idea.
So Frances has a different technique.
He finds people that have the talent and
he just gives them a long lead. It says,
you just go for it. You take it, take it.
And I want to see what you come up with.
And that was a good relationship.
What did,
what was different about the idea that
you presented? Uh, for the material?
I'll give you a clue, which was
the, his people is produced,
kept saying, when's the scoring date
date? I've been in the studio for a month.
We mean date, you know, the way they used
to do films was there to have a date.
And on the date they show up with the
orchestra and they record the music on
that day. And uh, that's the,
that's the recording session.
I don't do it like that.
I,
I'm in the studio by myself and
I play a little bit of drums,
then I add some guitar and then I settle
around over here and I'm working on
building it. Like, you make a record.
And I was gonna say that was just
completely an alien exercise. I mean,
the people would come down and they
said, this is kind of interesting. And,
but there was the moment
when Francis did turn around,
so this all sounds really fantastic.
And all of his old guys,
his crew that he'd been working with
forever, they're all thinking, wow,
this is really different on or anything
like that. But it kind of works.
I said crazy, but it kind
of works, you know? And um,
but it did turn around and say, I want the
strings. You know, I need some strings.
And I'm going, Oh shit, he's going to
hire some string schlocky guy, Francis,
you're so right.
You need strings.
I going to fix up some nice strings and
strings, you know, nice strings, strings.
And so I call up the contractor and said,
send me some strings. And he says, well,
okay, sure, fine. How
many strings? I Dunno,
how many strings is strings
send me some strengths,
you know? And so these,
I think it was maybe 1415 guys
showed up, you know, strings and a,
they arrive and usually
a recording session,
your guitar shows up and you
book them for the afternoon.
Then he comes in with his 10 guitars and
couple of apps with a bunch of pedals.
And he said, okay. So the first thing,
it's just kind of like
gay dad ain't doing India.
And then when it comes to that show,
get a shop of his name and you know
Matt Dillon and he's called it the,
you know that kid with a Bandanna.
Okay. On the shot of just kinda hit it,
you kind of thing there and then kind
of pull back a little bit in there and
then you, you know, and you're
talking to him like that.
And that's the way you work at. And the
guy who, oh cool, how about this? Maybe,
how about that? Try
that. Stratacap you know,
you talk and it's an interaction in
between the two of you collaborate and you
get it.
So the strings arrive a lot of them.
And so I go out to do my thing. Hey
guys, it's great to have you here.
It has movies, kind of an art
movie and you know, the first song,
it's kind of thinking that the guy that,
and then when you see
the guy with the Bandana,
it just kind of goes a
little long like that.
And I'm talking and
I'm talking about them.
And they're looking kind of
more and more uncomfortable.
And eventually one of them says, ah,
my stroke. Um, the one of the play,
what the music on the page here or
whatever the fuck you're talking about.
And I play the page by page.
And so they do invite the page. By
the way, in this case was footballs,
what they call this whole notes.
Nice.
Eh,
you know,
I didn't know how to write it.
I didn't know how to write
that music at that time.
So it was just the chords that
I was playing myself. Bling,
bling here, stop the tape. Okay.
Roll tape bleeding
and uh,
ear bought and put that on a chart
so that that's the top. No, no. Okay.
We'll give that the violin and violin
to viola and I had an arranger put it on
the page, you know, then
I need to study, you know,
I was a music major in
college so I could read it,
but I hadn't seen a sheet of music
in 20 years in rock and roll.
There are no sheets of music and it just,
it's just not part of the vocabulary.
But here with these
string players a section.
And so they have these footballs and
they say, well look, it's all footballs.
Can we just, uh, this is run it down and
everybody wants, you want to peek from
the thesis.
They go,
let's just down in a day,
day, day day did, okay,
cool. Okay. Roll tape. And they play
and they were done in like half an hour.
They just played what was on the page,
you know,
I didn't need to talk to them at all.
They just play was on the page and they
played it and there were, you know,
after the guitarist guy, he's
there all afternoon, you're
trying stuff. These guys,
it's on the page,
they play it exactly in their done.
Wow.
You meet. All I gotta do is
figure it out and do the homework,
put it on the stand and they plan.
So 20 years later I, you know,
I'd done maybe 40, 50
films, TV commercials, uh,
and all this stuff and you use
orchestra lot. And pretty soon I got,
I learned how to write down a little bit
of a battle and a fancy stuff. And, um,
the best part of it is that it's about
the home with a band you think on your
feet and it's an interaction.
Musicians of the ear musicians are
divided at birth into two categories.
Musicians of the ear and
musicians of the eye.
Musicians of the ear where I come from,
they're connected to the music by the ear.
They're staring off in space and they
just know when eight bars are up and they
know where to listen for the groove.
And they're part of that groove and
they're connected with their ear musicians
of the,
I read a chart and they,
their fingers follow what
their eyes told them to play.
And even the rhythm comes
from the conductor, a visual
cue, the conductor's baton.
It their eyes connect them to the
music and the musicians of the ear,
they just make that shit up. Uh,
it's, it's a collaborative way.
It's improvisational.
They know that it's ea and d,
but how are you going to hit that?
[inaudible] how are you going to which
inversion of a, you know, and so there's,
you know, it's the, it's a
collaboration. You work it out together,
it takes forever. Uh,
but an orchestral music,
you put it on the page and they will
play it. And like I said before,
it's not just Dah, Dah,
Dah, as dotted down,
you know that you put that shit and you
have to put all that shape on the page.
And if you do 60 guys,
then that guy over there on the double
bass and that guy way over there on
second violin and they're 30,
40 feet away from each other.
But each of them has their own
book with only their own part.
And if they follow exactly what's on
the page and execute it beautifully,
then they all,
all 60 of them become the
mighty Chicago symphony.
And that's where their ego lies.
Not from,
I'm gonna Express myself on
this part here. Goddamn it.
Even though I'm the third
chair, second violin, no,
their ego,
their pride in their work comes from these
corporate identity of the magnificent
orchestra of which they are part.
And by the way,
they're playing Mendelssohn
and Brahms and really,
really good music.
The best of the best of the best.
That has withstood the test of time.
So there's two completely
different musical universes and a,
I love jamming with guys who come over
to my studio and we jam and we just make
it up as we go along.
But I also love to do that homework and
get it on the page and conceive of every
aspect of it where the swell is,
where the surge,
the ebb and the flow in that violin lended
going up to there and he gets up high
like that and the Trump, it takes it over
and then go buy boom on the low brass.
Oh, I, you know, that's just really a
lot of fun to conceive of that stuff.
And then you go and you sit with the
orchestra and they play it and without
debate and the first time, what's
that? It's a little creaky.
The second time it's like wow.
And then by showtime it's really
good fun to play that stuff.
I like this question. This is
from James Stubbs, Facebook.
He's one of the few rock drummers
that plays traditional grip.
How did he come to play that way?
So maybe you could also explain
to people what this means. Well,
in Olden Times these snare
drum was a military instrument,
a former GE,
and to March with and the snare drums
or that deep cylinder like this and that
deep into march with it.
Like this is Kinda hard.
So what they do is they turn on its side
so that the drum is like that and you
can still march, which means to hit the
drum. Like this is kind of a problem.
So how about this hand hold the stick
like that and you create the drum?
Is that this angle? And now your
sticks can go like that because that,
whereas this would be a problem.
That's where it came from. Okay.
When they took the snare drum and put it
on a drum set and created the trap set
probably down in New Orleans or somewhere,
wherever they,
whoever had the idea of
assembling a bunch of drums. Uh,
and to the traps set, uh,
the snare drum was, you know,
the technique of playing it
still was this, you know,
both hands are not the same.
This is called match grip.
This is called Orthodox.
It's old school and just the practitioners
would set up this newly invented
contraption and have the snare
drum at that angle. Okay, years go.
And I learned from that, from, you know,
buddy rich and the gene Krupa style,
the my father, as soon as he spotted
me as a musician had me in lessons,
which meant Orthodox,
I book paradiddles and slamming it and
all the rudiments and everything with
this technique.
And then nowadays a drummer can set up
the drums at any how he darn well wants.
And these has it logically flat and
the Tom Tom Logically like that.
And what's this for?
So he plays like this nowadays.
Nowadays drummers all play match
decrypt. It makes perfect sense. Now,
in my opinion,
this is a bigger digit than this.
There's bigger muscles here,
so,
and I want to get that
backbeat look out baby.
This hammer's coming down with this
thumb to bring it down and it's a,
seems like a more stronger thing.
I Dunno.
It's not matched and say
you learned to make it set.
The effect is the same but
different mechanics in each hand.
Glad you asked.
[inaudible]
and the next one is from Masud Khan.
We don't have to do 10,
but he asked the 10 top 10 albums
you would take to another planet.
Let's just say three
albums. The old desert. Uh,
well any Hendrix album, but probably the
double one because it's a double one.
A, which would be the third one.
Uh, access. No, not access. Um,
what was the third one?
Voodoo child or visited double album.
All the naked girls on bicycles. Uh,
I'll go, I'll go Google it later.
Anyhow, that's one. Uh,
I'm not a huge Beatles fan,
but I would probably take either the
white album or sergeant pepper just cause
the variety. If we're going to be
stuck on that island for a long time,
we need some variety.
Um,
and uh,
probably some blues just
cause it makes me feel good.
But then again I could play blues myself.
No, I wouldn't take a blues record. Uh,
I dunno. Some classical, some Stravinsky,
probably write some
spring or Patrice scheme.
And if you're out of the running,
if you had to combine since say three
drummers alive or dead into your sort of
perfect super drummer,
who would they be and why?
I would take the majesty of John Bottom.
He achieved with very few drum strokes,
very sides,
but boom,
boom.
It just sounds like a mountain. And
everybody, nobody has gotten there,
figured out how to make a drum set.
Sounds so huge.
And it's the economy and it's
the way he hits the drum.
Just some magic about the way he played,
created size,
just hugeness.
Then I would take uh,
God, I'm terrible with names.
Uh, James Brown's drummer,
stubble fields, double
anyone here. Anyone cried?
Stubblefield for funk cause
we've got a dance, you know,
and he's not a star guy,
but just give me some of that.
And so we're all be dancing and
those few Dender will be, you know,
doing what they do.
Uh,
and then I would take Mitch Mitchell
for technique or buddy rich.
What about the technique?
Just the effervescence,
the lively spark of either,
it'd be tough between, uh,
I mean buddy rich is the number.
He is the absolute top God
whether you like his music or not,
there's nobody who's been able to
achieve just the manual dexterity,
let alone the artistry and
everything else. I mean,
he really isn't a class of his own.
Mitch Mitchell is up there as well,
but he had, he was, his music was more fun
and more effervescent and, and science.
I'd probably take John Bonham,
Clyde Stubblefield and,
and Mitch Mitchell since we saw you
tearing it up in the first video that we
showed. This next question is
from I am Keith Andrew on Twitter.
What weaknesses in your playing or
writing or composing bug you and are you
fighting to overcome? How do
you fight them? Uh, arthritis.
Uh, and right now I play with
an orchestra and my drums, uh,
are designed to play to
accompany amplified instruments,
which can be any amount of volume,
you know,
so Dominic and range of the rock and roll
drummer goes from seven to 12 guitar.
It's only go to 11 and
drummers. And by the way,
we don't do it by turning a little
mob. We do it by hitting it. And, uh,
in the orchestra,
the orchestra feels very loud,
but it's in fact a quarter
of the volume of a rock band.
And when you go to a concert
and you see an orchestra play,
it feels emotionally really big.
But physics wise,
it's actually much more quiet.
And so you have the huge rockstar and
you put the drug in their crack and the
orchestra is God, they're
toast. You can't hear him,
nothing because the drums are so low.
So the biggest challenge
has been to play quietly.
And I now after years of playing with
orchestras and working on it, and,
and I practiced with the
music, barely audible. So I, I,
I can't accompanied unless I get it
down there. And a couple of things.
First of all, less work. Second of
all, the drum sound so much better.
Third of all,
all kinds of finesse of technique that I
learned as a kid but never could use in
rock and roll. They just have,
we never hear the, you know,
a rough or a drag, you know, you can't
hear them in rock roll. Now you can.
So they sound great, cool
technique, less work.
And so learning how to play that quietly,
I can now play a fawn drum set,
my drum set designed for the
aforementioned cacophony. Uh,
and there's a violin solo that I wrote,
a nice little violin solo and
she's 30 feet away and I'm not the,
and I can now play so quietly, but I
can hear her and soak in the audience,
you know, and uh, that,
that's an achievement is the,
as we mentioned, arthritis,
is that, is that a real issue there
you're contending with? Absolutely. Yeah.
They're there. They're there on the
y. How do my thoughts, how do you,
how do you deal with that? Well,
I find that if I, you know,
I don't look at my drums until I've
got a show coming up in this year.
I've had shows coming up all year,
so I've been in shape and so I have to
start up. It's like rocky, you know,
I start slow and I work it up and I
have little things like that to get,
you know,
and I find that when I get fit
to play and I'm up to speed,
the arthritis goes away and it doesn't
return until I walk away from the drums.
And I don't even look at them
until next time I have to.
And then the arthritis creeps back in,
opening a door out.
If it's locked a locked
door. Ah, man, that's hurts,
you know? And, uh, and I think Darren,
this is really inconvenient for what I do,
but in fact,
when I started playing drums, when I
get fit, you know, it's not a problem.
Did you do anything else for self
care in the hands or the yeah,
there's the stretches.
I have a thing that I got in China,
which is like our little
pointy soft wooden thing that I
just sort of massage the muscles.
And like I say that there's
quite a fash fetish.
I'm pretty familiar with the structure
of the hand and there's 10 bones there
and like all this really complicated,
but I'm pretty into making it
work and playing at that volume.
It's just isn't the stress that it is at
high volume. So this might be related,
but a next question is from
tinker coffee co at tinker Topica.
What's the most technical
but underappreciated skill
for our drummer to possess
a, I would say that quiet thing quiet. Um,
because I have drummers who have that
range dynamic range of seven to 12.
Uh, and that's just really hard work. You
know, my, my buddy, uh, fishermen in fish,
he's really quiet.
He's been doing that.
Oh and I saw a bad guy and you know,
you see them from the front and it's
blazing cause there's a 50 zillion watt PA
system to make it louder.
He doesn't need to make it ladder and
saw the sign this and watching and he's
just comfy. He's hardly breaking
a sweat. I'm going to do that,
you know,
and playing quietly.
That's the most unappreciated technique
that I would say to answer that question.
All right, well given that you're,
you're, so you're talking, uh,
sort of categories are the, do not
discuss lists for dinner conversation.
If you were to give a Ted talk,
let's say,
or some high profile talk 20 minutes long,
but you couldn't talk about music,
couldn't talk about drumming,
nothing that you're known for,
but maybe some secret obsession or thing
that you study on the weekends or in
the evenings or anything for that matter.
What you talk about,
Old Testament Theology,
Old Testament theology.
Yeah. All right, well tell us more.
I grew up in the holy land
and they're still arguing
about it now to this day. Uh,
who's is it and a which religion prevails.
And it turns out that the three religions
fighting most vociferously over that
piece of real estate are
the same religion. Uh,
they come from the same book.
And the Old Testament is that book in the
Old Testament is unique because I also
love Egyptian history. You know, I
think Moses was a jackass. You know,
th th th the Egyptian
history was a beautiful,
beautiful thing as described
in the old testament. You know,
the Egyptians were great people with
great values of beautiful culture,
but the people who wrote the
Old Testament didn't think so.
So the Egyptians describe their
enemies in these pejorative terms and,
and turn are described by the
Israelites in these pejorative terms.
It's fascinating because in the
Egyptian history, there was no plagues.
There was no Moses,
there was no exodus.
And so obviously the exodus and the
events referred to in the Old Testament,
there's something happened
historically to PR to,
to create what became these stories.
You know,
there's gotta be an origin to these
stories. Which feral was that?
Which part of Egyptian history was
that? Um, you know, traditionally it's,
it's Ramsey too, you know, the big
one just because he's the biggest,
but it wasn't man, you figured out
there are these different chronologies.
There's the archeology. Uh, or
let's start with the Old Testament,
which says that a thousand
years ago, Moses did this, uh,
so many thousand year ago, Solomon
Solomon did that and there's a chronology.
Then there's the Egyptian chronology,
which has its list of kings and
it's not measured in 1927 nights.
It's like this king in the third
year of King Center. Kreb the second,
and it's like you have to know how many,
there's that chronology.
Then there's the archeology.
The strata of Jericho,
for instance, tells us that there
was no burning down of Jericho.
When the Bible says that they
came, the came, you know,
they came and burned down Jericho. None
happened folks. Jericho has been burned,
but not when the Bible says it did a
couple of 3000 years early. Well, okay,
well let's pull that.
Bob will call you down.
Pull this one up so that that matches now.
Well then we've got a problem with the
Egyptian chronology, so we stretch that.
Then Shit, you know, and
the period of Solomon,
there are no great architectural
masterpieces or anything to denote a great
kingdom during the time of Solomon.
It doesn't mean he didn't exist.
It means that the chronology of when the
Bible said he exists might be a little
inaccurate.
So you like,
that's what I can find
endlessly fascinating.
Wow. Okay. Okay. I know,
I know, I know, I know
I lost you.
I totally lost you there for a minute,
but I'm going to bring you back. Okay.
Over in the west side of Los Angeles,
there's all these private schools where
all US fancy folks send our kids and
there's only a few of us,
they have these school gala fundraising
events.
Where they raised money is if they need
to raise money and they have this gala
event and they have, you know, all
the bands, you know, and uh, you know,
we got to all the dads is going
to be some rock stars in there.
And so they have, you know, I
call what I call the grateful dad,
which is the school band, um, of whatever
dads are in that school. And you know,
one of the schools here at Wildwood,
the school,
the grateful dad was Stephen Stills.
Gene Simmons,
me a Barclay,
um,
Travis bark glee
miles in a wheelchair,
kind of a wrap.
[inaudible] and Bob, Bob Dylan was
supposed to be there but he bailed.
So that's the bad gene Simmons
Steven stills in me. Okay.
That's pretty disparate.
What we've figured out a show we
played for all the dads. Okay.
Turns out that Gene Simmons is a
student of Old Testament theology.
So they're at this event where
we're playing all this stuff.
Like there's the Bass player of kiss
and the drummer of police backstage are
agreeing about which profit knows that.
But Diet was not those
[inaudible]
very well read guy.
Are there any quotes?
Is there a quote or quotes that you either
live your life by or think of often?
Don't worry.
Be Happy.
All right.
[inaudible] by the way,
by the way,
that's is the first thing that came to
my mind and thank you for that. Nice,
polite pleather. What the fuck
does that mean? What uses that?
Don't worry.
Be Happy as if is there a pill for that?
So good advice. But it is
good advice. Kind of facile.
So we can also come back to
that one. If anything, if any,
if there's someone who is particularly
quotable in your mind in a way that has
impacted you, maybe that's another
way to tackle it. Uh, you know,
for me it would be a Seneca, maybe an
Emerson. Wow, that's sophisticated. Well,
I mean Seneca, no, I'll show you how
unsophisticated I am. So from Long Island,
I thought Seneca was,
and there is another Seneca and fairness,
but a native American elder for
the longest time I was like,
this guy's the best quote ever.
That was like, oh wait, he's a,
Roman has been dead for 2000 years.
But that was a football team or city.
And he does a lot of things. Seneca
has been used for a lot of labeling.
If you
saying giving advice to a young musician,
very capable musician who's
getting ready for their first,
would they perceive to be big Gig?
And they're just all nerves.
They are. They feel like
they've got a bottom. Yeah.
By the way, a presenter of
a television show, it could
have been made. What advice,
what advice would you give
that person? Relax, relax.
Take that as your living room. It's
um, well that particular thing,
there's a bunch of
specific to that challenge,
which is that there are audiences on your
side. You're getting your, your, your,
you walk out on stage as a total success
and it's yours to throw away and it's
really hard to throw away,
you know? Um, so relax,
assume that you're blowing everybody away.
Um,
and everything else will take care of
itself. You know, when I was young,
I used to think that I got to get myself
out to go on stage and I got to go out.
But in fact, that's a dissipation
of the energy, you know,
there was that film whiplash where the
kid is trying to get better and he goes
back to woodshed,
may show him the woodshed.
That's the one thing they got
wrong. Yeah. Uh, to get better,
you don't grow like
that. You go like that,
you know, calmly. And the more
relaxed you can be, the more energy,
the more ferocity you can achieve
by being relaxed. You know,
definitely mass murder is
best delivered cold. Is that
well, I mean I revenge is best
served. Oh yeah. There we go.
The uh,
80 act of violence has more aggression
and violence if it's done commonly.
Well, you also see this in a athletics,
right? I mean, it's kind of a nervous,
evil laugh going around the room.
This little chorus of Dr Evil Laugh.
That's all right. Yeah. Uh, I mean,
you see the wives check your husbands,
you see the ability to teach
for an off informing the ability
to turn out, right. I mean,
you see this in athletics all the time,
meaning the,
the someone's capacity to turn off and
relax being directly correlated to their
ability to turn it on if they're
always on or somewhere in the middle.
It just doesn't seem to
manifest the same way.
I remember hearing this story
about a gent named Marcello Garcia,
so he's considered sort of the
Michael Jordan, Mike Tyson,
Wayne Gretzky combined to the Brazilian
Jujitsu world is something like a nine
time world champion. And I know, uh,
a fellow who co owns a school that,
and Marcel has gone to
the world championships,
biggest event of the year on the planet
and he's supposed to go into the finals
and they call his name to go out to the
mat and he's asleep. And the bleachers,
they had to go shake him to wake
him up and he's sort of groggy,
rubbing his eyes, walks out. And
then as soon as he steps on the mat,
just different person,
I,
I totally that you get yourself into a
state of calmness and the ferocity we'll
take care of itself. I had a similar
thing I, the other day I was,
and playing in Seattle with the
Seattle symphony, they're doing,
Ben Hurts a 90 minute
program with big orchestra,
really complex show my hotel rooms just
around the corner. So I go back after,
you know,
rehearsal and I'm,
and I set my alarm for six o'clock
and I got into a sneeze. Ah,
I set it for 6:00 AM not
pm. Ah. So I wake up,
oh like that.
And I got a bit of a sandwich and I'm
chewing on the sandwich and I look at,
Oh shit. So I run, you know like Oh God,
Oh God,
Oh God the hell it and I'm on the 28th
floor elevator out of service down the
step up the hell do they
get get there like that. And
Ah, okay. Showtime.
Best show ever.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work
week.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by kettle and fire,
which makes some of the best bone broth
and certainly the most convenient that
I've ever found and I have a big stack
of them on my kitchen counter right now I
have one container every morning and this
first came highly recommended to me by
past podcast guests such as Amelia Boone
who is a four time world champion in
bolts, toughest mudder, Spartan
race, etc. And Dr Dominic D'agostino,
the incredible hulk of scientific
research. He's checking him out too.
But there are few things that make a
kettle and fire special. Number one,
they are the first shelf stable.
In other words,
never frozen bone broth that
uses bones from 100% grass fed,
organically raised animals.
So you are what you eat,
ate,
if that makes sense.
So it's very important that you understand
if you're consuming animal protein,
what they consumed. They also use
longer cook times, 20 plus hours,
which means more collagen and
other nutrients. For instance,
they contain it 19 times more Collagen,
then one of their close competitors
and an independent lab confirm this.
I'll leave the competitor's name out
of it because I don't want to get sued,
but that's the case and it is not frozen.
So thanks to many millions of
dollars of packaging equipment.
They're bone broth doesn't require
freezing or shipping with dry ice.
So like I said,
it's just sitting on my kitchen counter
in these boxes and then I can keep them
up.
They're basically ready to drink,
heat them up on the stove top or in a
microwave and you are ready to rock and
roll. And you'll also get a nice
payload of Glucosamine, glycine, uh,
along with the gelatin and everything
else that I mentioned. So check it out.
I've been hugely pleased
with this and like I said,
had been consuming it every morning.
It gives you about let's
say 20 grams of protein,
which is a nice little slow carb diet
boost. That's what you're looking for it.
And then I'll typically sip this,
have a very large camping coffee mug as
I do some writing or journaling so that
you'll have it. Check
it out. It's delicious.
I favor the chicken,
but uh,
each to his own or her own. So
check it out. Kettle and fire.com,
forward slash timber and you can
receive 20% off of your entire order.
Take a look. Kettling
fire.com forward slash. Tip.
It is very late at night.
I am packing for an island getaway.
Why does that matter?
Because it reminds me of one
of the sponsors for today's
podcast visiting Maine.
Why? Because the only dress
shirt that I'm taking,
I normally hate dress shirts
is from mizzen and main,
specifically the Becket Blue Gingham.
The reason or the reasons I should say
is because I can throw it in my bag and
the duffle,
not worry about ironing,
not worry about any kind of wrinkling
and then throw it on where it may be four
or five nights out of seven without
washing it. It won't smell antimicrobial.
It is made of stretch,
fabric, sweat wicking,
athletic. I could wear for a hike in
between dinners if I want to do it,
probably wouldn't do that.
But mizzen and main has really delivered
on the all around all purpose dress
shirt.
They're fancy enough.
You can fool people into thinking
that you had them custom tailored,
but they're also rough
enough and resilient enough
that you can toss them into
the bottom of a duffle bag or backpack,
pull it off and put it on in
a bathroom at a restaurant.
Let's say hundreds of pro
athletes love this brand. Uh,
people who don't fit well
into dress shirts, otherwise
like NFL Allpro, Jj Watt.
And the last time these guys were featured
on the show visit domain sold out of
every item that they featured. So if
you're interested in checking them out,
I had to recommend taking a look.
Just go to tim.blog forward slash shirts,
and you can see that one
shirt that I'm packing.
Then I always pack the Beckett
Hulu Gingham in addition
to a couple of my other
favorites.
And you can enter Tim,
that's Capitol Tim at
checkout for free shipping.
If you use this code before September
15th it's 2017 to buy a dress shirt mizzen
and main,
we'll donate a brand new dress shirt to
the relief efforts in southern Texas.
That's in addition to the thousand shirts
that are already being donated through
Jj Watson. Credible efforts
to put our, I should say,
where help Houston and the surrounding
communities get back on their feet.
So there you have it.
Check it out. Take a look.
Even if it's just to take
a peek at this one shirt,
the Becket tim.blog/shirts.
Again, that's Tim dot.
Blog forward slash shirts.